Amber Rose opens up about body
positivity and being a natural woman
extremely important
et spoke with the 32 year old model at
her second annual [ __ ] walk in Los
Angeles on Saturday this is a
no-judgment zone we're out here we're
embracing everyone this is very positive
and very loving it's important to feel
self-confident because that's gonna get
you through the day and through your
life so just know that every woman has
stretch marks every woman has cellulite
I definitely do my boobs day I'm not
perfect and you know I'm just very blunt
open about all those things because I'm
a natural girl and I'm a human being to
have a voice and to have a platform I I
like to speak out on those things
because you know people are listening
friends like blac Chyna Kendra Wilkinson
and her Dancing with the Stars partner
Maksim Chmerkovskiy all attended the
walk and amber revealed all that support
made her emotional I'm overwhelmed with
happiness I you know it's like almost
cried for a second I probably will cry
throughout the day but um you know it's
beautiful it really is and and I'm happy
that I have all this support one thing
amber didn't address was the drama over
being body shamed by Dancing judge
Julianne Hough
but Julian's brother and dancing pro
derek hough did speaking to et's Carly
Steele while he was on the red carpet at
the MPT F event on Saturday Giuliana's B
is a huge advocate for for being kind
and especially remember empowering women
so definitely definitely was not